Allham.
Continuing
[Silence]
in
the book of the miscellaneous narrations
and various stories
in the chapters regarding
Adj. dead and the signs of the day of
judgment and
it's coming.
And so
a lot of the narrations having to do
with a a lot of the narrations having to
do with the day of judgment etc. Many
of these narrations are now concluded
proceeds to go into narrations that are
general. They don't necessarily fall
into any particular subject such as
stories or
pieces of advice
words to live by etc.
And so
one of the narrations that and now we
mention
is an narration
regarding
was known
for his understanding his his
subs
his father was a judge and a king and he
learned
kingship and judgment from his father
but as well he later grew up and became
a prophet as well. And this wisdom that
he was given at such a young age was
perfected when he received revelation
from Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala.
And so
was given a kingship that was greater
and more expansive than his fathers.
And he was guided personally by Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala in his judgment even
at a young age in a way that even his
father had not been.
And
was given a zab which is translated to
the psalms. Wasam
given a book. unlikely
most likely followed in suit on based on
the book of his father as zabul that his
father was given. So we will now hear a
story that our prophet sallallah.aii
tells us about
and some of the wisdom that he had.
for
[Silence]
Well, Bkari was Muslim
in Bkari. Abu narrates to us that in the
time of
there were two women. One of them was
older than the other. So we have an old
woman, an older woman and a younger
woman. Both of them, each of them had a
child. Now what happened is a wolf
actually got away with one of the
children, one of the boys. So one of
these two women was hence bererieved.
And so
the one that her child remained and the
one who had her child taken by the wolf
both laid claim to that child, the
remaining child. Meaning one of them is
lying. One of them is telling the truth
and that is her child. The other one
feels her child was taken from her.
This is my child. Actually, he took
yours kind of thing. And so they went to
and
judged based on what he was presented
judge the child to be to the elder
woman. So as they left and had watched
this he then said come here tell me the
story etc.
And so he did not agree with the
judgment of his father.
And so what he did was he said, "I'm
going to take a knife and cut him in
half. That way each of you will get a
half. Everybody's happy, right? Cut the
kid in half, you get a half, you get a
the other half, everybody goes home with
equal portions." And so immediately as
he threatened to do this,
he had both the authority to do this and
he had both the ability to do this.
The younger one chimed in and said, "No,
no, no, don't do it. It's actually
hers."
So which one did Sleman
based on that new piece of information,
which one of the two women did he judge
the child to be to?
Why?
Huh?
Because she's more worried about the
child. See, the older one, she's
bereaveved.
Misery loves company. We've heard this
before. If my child is taken, that's
hard for me. But if I can get your child
to be taken from you as well, we can
both be in the same position.
Right?
And so the older one is fine with that.
Cut him in half. I'm good with that. But
the younger one, she is not speaking
from a place of bereiement. She is
speaking from a place of current
motherhood.
being that the child will be with me and
I only get a half of him so he loses his
life or the child goes on to live but he
doesn't live with me. A true mother by
instinct would choose what would choose
the life of the child over her own
satisfaction.
And so
was his judgment was that the child was
to the younger one. What do we
understand from this? Do we understand
from this that Doud was mistaken
in the way that he judged? No.
But being a judge is a lot more than
just
weighing the various variables,
the variables. Okay, the various
variables weighing the various issues
that arise. That's only one part of
judgment.
A true judge is the one who is able to
bring out information that is
deliberately being hidden by the
plaintiff or the defendant. This is the
mark, the hallmark of the true wisdom of
a judge. Allah's judgment is clear. It's
in the Quran. The judgment of a case
this is that the child goes with
his biological mother and the other
woman has nothing to get. We all know
that judgment. We all know that.
However, the skill here of judgment
isn't the final conclusion or isn't the
final judgment. The skill here and the
wisdom is getting that additional piece
of information
that will
make the judge able to properly cast
his judgment and that is what
was given in this case and there's other
cases as well and so Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala says
we personally Ally made to understand
the issue. Not just to understand the
judgment. Both he and Dood know the
judgment. The difference was knowing the
variables. The difference was knowing
the things that were actively being
hidden by the people involved in the in
the case. This is the part that takes
skill, that takes years of experience.
And this is what we refer to as a
that is making a judgment based on
based on certain
circumstantial evidence. The Quran is
circumstantial evidence. We see Ysefam.
He is running from the woman who's
trying to seduce him. She grabs she rips
his garment that he's wearing.
And so the judgment was
she claims he was forcing himself on
her. He claims that she was forcing
herself on him.
How do we figure this out? Well, if the
clothing is torn from the front, then
this means that he was facing her when
the conflict took place. Whereas, if it
was torn from the back, this means that
he was faced away from her when the
conflict took place. And so, Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala secured
Ysef's innocence by this by this
circumstantial piece of evidence. Why do
we call it circumstantial evidence?
Circumstantial evidence is not in itself
completely objective. It can be
interpreted in a various ways.
Circumstantial evidence can be
interpreted in more than one way. But
when we place it in the bigger picture,
it can only fit by being interpreted in
the correct way. This is called a
parena. And surahf is filled with this.
All of the stories of the prophets are
filled with this. And this is where the
real wisdom and skill of a judge comes
comes to play. And so
was shown at even a very young age that
Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala one of his
miracles that he had every prophet has
miracles is that Allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala gave him the ability to elicit
details that are being actively hidden
in order that his judgment will be true.
And so the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam gives us an example of that in
this narration. This narration is very
well known and circulated amongst the
scholars of hadith as you've heard it's
reported by both bkari and Muslim which
means it's been given a lot of attention
by the scholarship of Islam and for good
reason. It contains in it a nugget of
that wisdom that
had. So and both wise and both know the
judgment of Allah. However, what changed
the circumstantial evidence?
was able to elicit circumstantial
evidence that swayed the entirety of the
judgment and this was one of his
miracles.
Now when we compare two people and I'll
show you one of the one of the most
brilliant things
ways of speaking in the Quran.
If I were to say
the best person here or the best of us
is let's say the best of us is mubin
methan
nobody feels bad particularly right all
of us are here there's a lot of us it
doesn't feel directed at anyone it is a
praise of mubin but if I said mubin is
better than yaser
Now what happens
now? Yes, it feels bad. And not only
that, but the people listening
automatically assume that yes, it has
something wrong with
him, right? There's a very subtle
difference. And for this reason, we say
and it is the sunnah to say the prophet
Muhammad sallall.aii wasallam is the
best of the prophets.
However, it is not correct to say
Muhammad is better than MS.
You see the difference there? There is a
difference because one does not entail
the depreciation of the rest of the
prophets. Whereas one to one now
articulates something that is.
So in the Quran, Allah compensates for
this in the verses speaking about.
Listen to what Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
says.
[Silence]
Notice how Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
deals with this delicately.
He says that and both judged their
judgments were contradicting
and sle was correct.
That means daw was incorrect. Right? So
Allah says,
"And so we made it so that Sullean
understood it, but we gave both of them
wisdom and knowledge."
So he compensates for that because if
you think
is better than that's not what's
intended by the verse rather Allah says,
look at what happened between De and
Sleman. So a man was correct. But both
of them were of great esteem. So now
both of them are still of a very lofty
level. They are both thought of in a
great manner rather than one being
deficient and the other being you
know elevated over the other. And for
this reason the prophet sallall.aii
alaihi wasallam said
that's the meaning of the hadith and
he said do not give me
do not say that I am better than any
one of the prophets any one of the
prophets
the story of this narration is that in
the marketplace one of the Muslims said
I swear by the Lord of Muhammad.
And the other said, I swear by the Lord
of Musa.
And so the Muslims slapped him when he
said that.
And so they went he went and complained.
The Jewish man went and complained to
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam.
And so the prophet sallallah.aii alaihi
wasallam said do not praise me over any
one of the prophets. He didn't say don't
praise me over the prophets in general.
Say Muhammad is the im of the prophets,
the messengers.
There's no problem with that. The
problem is it's Muhammad versus MS. He
says don't do that. Why? because it
causes the listener to assume that MS is
less than what he is and to take away
from his lofty position.